Many of you know, I was born in Argentina.
My family came to the United States when I
was five years old because the economy was
terrible in Argentina in 1989 and since then,
Argentina has had um, uh, downs and bigger
downs and very few ups quite frankly. And
things are now acutely imploding in Argentina.
And I thought I would talk about it a little
bit. The economy in Argentina has been disastrous
for a long time now. I mean, really leading
all the way back to when my family left in
1989. Uh, it's been a combination of inflation,
foreign debt, terrible leaders, uh, not properly
managing natural resources and, and, uh, other
resources, uh, in a both sustainable but economically
advantageous way.
Anything you can imagine basically has gone
bad in Argentina. Now, Christina Kershner
was president from 2007 to 2015 and she was
one of the most corrupt presidents in a long
time. And to say that in Argentina, that says
a lot, elicit self enrichment, literally flying
millions of dollars in cash out of the country
on small planes. Devastating the Argentinian
economy in a lot of ways. A lot actually like
Hugo Chavez in Venezuela raping and pillaging,
Argentina's resources for her own gain while
touting populous sounding rhetoric and being
ostensibly quote on the left, but not have
any left that, uh, I can consider myself a
part of now. She ultimately lost in 2015 and
was replaced by, by Mauricio Mcity. Mockery
is very different from Kirschner, but also
problematic. Less overtly and cartoonishly
corrupt but a center, right? Trumpy and vulture
capitalists. I mean, literally a friend of
Donald Trump's who was looking at doing some
Trump projects in Argentina.
He did some good things. He's done some infrastructure
stuff, a high speed city bus in Bueno situs
putting money into public works and some other
infrastructure. But meanwhile, the Argentinian
peso has continued to fall in value and the
inflation has continued unheard of inflation
by American standards. Really horrible stuff.
To give you a sense, back in 2016, the exchange
rate was about 13 to one Argentinian peso
to u s dollar. In the last few months, it's
gotten as high or as low as 45 Argentinian
pesos to one US dollar. Terrible for everyone
in Argentina creates all sorts of problems
that gets us to this past Sunday, Sunday,
Argentina had sort of the equivalent of the
primary that are called Botso p ASO, which
stands for something, which I forget. Uh,
and but it's a different primary, it's a,
a, uh, an election to determine who will be
on the final election ballot.
But it's people from all parties and the top
vote getters are on the final ballot ballot.
And it turns out that Christina Kershner is
back on the ballot, not as president, but
as vice president to another guy named Fernandez.
Now, what you have to understand is that Christina
Kershner is Kirschner because her husband
who was also a president in Argentina, uh,
was last name Kirschner, her unmarried, her
unmarried name, maiden name, I don't know
if that's an inappropriate term, was Fernandez.
So the whole Gimmick here is Fernandez and
Fernandez, a guy named Fernandez with Christina
Fernandez as a, as his running mate and they
get the plurality of the vote in the Paso
elections, 43% of the vote. Meanwhile, there
have been indictments of Christina that had
potential prison time attached to them, which
will likely go nowhere. And now she is one
step closer to being back in the pink house,
the Argentinian equivalent, uh, of the White
House of the United States.
It is very likely with 43%. It is very likely
that Fernandez and Fernandez are going to
win the general election in October. And of
course this is instantly disastrous. The peso
collapses even more going in one day from
44 point something to one to 53 to one. Okay,
this is a single day currency devaluation
of more than 20% in one day. And things are
so blindly hyper-partisan in Argentina that
immediately the pro Cristina people say the
currency crash after the election results
was because a lots of corrupt people in marketing's
administration are realizing the game is over
and they are now getting their money out of
the country, which is crashing the currency.
That's an allegation of which there is actually
no evidence at this point in time. So bottom
line, even in my family, there are big divisions
on Argentinian politics. I don't talk with
them about any of it.
Part of it is I live in the United States.
I don't want to be the outsider who, when
I go visit a, starts pretending to know everything
and, and, uh, uh, of a situation that they
are living day to day. But it is so toxic
and people say such insane things to either
defend or attack whoever isn't on their side.
But the bottom line is this is looking very
bad. The currency is increasingly worth less
and less. This makes people salaries worth
less and less. This makes inflation go up.
They're on the verge of putting back in one
of the biggest, uh, rapers and pillagers of,
uh, the Argentinian economy that there has
been. And uh, even people who have what would
be reasonably good jobs and many countries
are very poorly off as a result of what is
going on with currency and inflation and everything
else.
It's sad. I think things are going to be quite
frankly, extraordinarily screwed up for a
very long time in Argentina. And now the calls
are starting for [inaudible] to not even stay
until the general election in October. Like
just to leave the Christina people are saying
you have to go now because you staying as
an effective lame duck until October is terrible
for the economy and the markets implode and
you've just got to go. If you think that talking
to a Trumpist is difficult, try talking politics
in Argentina. It's really, really bad.